Let's see. I said whatever this something is could be replaced with ω².
Check it out. The something in this case--the something that multiples our x is k/m.
If I know k and I know ω, I can get m, but I don't know ω. I know period.
Why don't I get ω from that period.
Well, in this case the period is 1 second so ω is just 2π.
Okay, well, now I know that ω², 2π² is equal to k/m--50/m.
Well, all I have to do now is solve this equation for m.
When I do, I find that I need a mass of 1.27 kg.
Okay, this was a little tricky.
The take away I want you to remember is that any time you can write your force like this,
acceleration equals negative something times x,
you're going to get simple harmonic motion. That's really incredible.
Not only that--whatever this something is will be the square of your angular frequency.
Now, that's really cool, but unfortunately all this stuff we've learned about springs--
well, springs weren't how they made the first clocks or first chronometers.
There was one day when our good friend Galileo while sitting in a church saw something
that blew his mind and would forever change navigation.
Le'ts talk to Tjeerd Bucker again to see what Galileo found.
[Tjeerd Bucker, Museum Booerhaave] Well, it's a rumor or an anecdote--however you want to call it.
Galileo was sitting in this church, and see the chandelier swinging from left to right,
and he checked with his pulse to see if it kept an accurate rate.
Due to counting, he found out that there was an equal line in oscillation,
an isochronism, in the pendulum in the swinging of the chandelier.
That's how the pendulum started life, really.